hi guys so I'm pretty excited because
this weekend is VidCon and I have some
announcements to make and here's my list
so that I don't mess up and stray from
what I really want to tell you guys
because this video end up being like 20
minutes and you'll want to punch me and
I don't have an attention span and I
know that you probably don't either so
okay VidCon is this weekend I can't wait
to meet so many of you guys and if you
can't make it out I'm sorry you'll just
have to come next year and then we can
meet and hang out so my meetup i believe
is on friday at three fifteen and that's
in meetup room to a lot of these
schedules are tentative so be sure to
check my twitter if you want to meet up
and there's another youtuber who you're
looking to meet check their twitters
it's okay to stalk us at this event also
at in my meat up I'm gonna have some
t-shirts I made up a bunch of them for
you guys so be sure to get there and get
a t-shirt I also have some stickers so
come by say hi take a picture hang out
and yeah look forward to meeting you on
Saturday I'm gonna be moderating the
women of vlog vedika panel at nine-forty
in the morning so be sure to wake up
early and at 12 10 there's gonna be an
ask IJ live so be sure to get there and
asked some good questions and please
don't ask me what editing software I use
because I use final cut pro so I don't
want to have to answer that one live
t-shirts now I'm pretty excited because
I finally launched my european store and
an i Justine t-shirt designer so you can
go to iJustine spreadshirt com and
there's some links up there and if you
want to design your own t-shirt you can
do that you can take any of my designs
change their color put that on any color
t-shirt but they want to bag put them on
a hat pretty much do whatever you want
now if you guys have already bought a
t-shirt that's awesome if you haven't
and plan on doing so I'm gonna have a
dailybooth thread that you guys can post
pictures of you wearing my t-shirt and I
can use them in an upcoming video if you
enter iJustine to the checkout starting
this weekend you guys can get free
shipping too so that is a plus another
thing that I wanted to mention that a
lot of you guys don't know is i have
another youtube account it's youtube.com
slash other iJustine and sometimes if i
don't post on this channel for a week
you guys are like hey why don't you
posting videos most likely that's
because i'm posting them in my other
channel i have tons of logs over there
and some people subscribe to this main
channel for edited videos like music
videos and ask i JS and then if you want
other kinds of stuff that's pretty much
everything else that's on the other
channel so feel free to subscribe there
i'm going
Hosting probably videos every day from
VidCon and then posting a big video here
another thing is 00 last on my list
cheeseburger cheeseburger i bought a
cheeseburger wallet and i bought another
wallet for one of you guys i was pretty
excited because obviously you guys know
I love cheeseburgers um I'll also post a
link in the description of the
dailybooth link that i posted this
little contest so you just have to go
there poster picture response and i'm
gonna be picking one of you guys
this cheeseburger wallet is a seriously
to the coolest thing you've ever seen
it's pretty amazing last but not least
on my list is I love you and I love you
guys you're amazing and just wanted to
thank you for being so awesome and I
look forward to meeting so many of you
guys this weekend and oh one other thing
i have a new music video coming out this
Friday it's about subscribers here's a
little preview what you gonna do with
all those songs all themselves inside
that box I know you don't have to say I
know I'm the best singer in the world I
mean that's already been established by
all of my great songs it doesn't matter
i still have fun and i thank you guys
for watching and putting up with my
horrible singing voice maybe one day i
will get a vocal instructor and they
will tell me justine there's no hope for
you and yeah that's how it's gonna go
all right i'm gonna stop rambling um
yeah i hope to see many of you VidCon
and I'll see you guys later my subs my
sauce myself my lovely little subs check
him out